[Musique]
pourquoi tu bosses tu perds pas
regarde-moi n'écoute que ma voix je ne
te laisserai pas jean on est une salle
du gesù
quoi qu'il arrive
regarde
tu es unique it in
[Musique]
si tu cesses de lutter contre la force
qui l'habitent
ce
l'afld etienne
tu disposera du pouvoir d'un dieu
elle va tous deux tués
[Musique]
dites-moi ce qu'on peut faire charles
dites moi quoi faire ses pâques rochelle
ceux qui ne comprennent pas
ils le craignent est ce qu'ils craignent
ils cherchent à le détruire
c'est votre faute charles
je voulais la protéger
j'ai peur de ça
quand je ne me contrôle plus il arrive
malheur je refusais il faut la détruire
c'est toujours jean on peut quand même
l'aider
on voudrait parfois que les gens soient
ceux qu'ils ne sont pas
et quand on comprend enfin qui ils sont
il est trop tard
elle arrive
[Musique]
raconte mon histoire c'est une histoire
qui parle de voyage de voyage pour se
mettre à l'épreuve
davanture d'une magie puissante une
magie qui dépasse tout ce qu'on a pu
ressentir jusqu'à présent de ce que
signifie aimer et être aimé de courage
de fraternité
[Musique]
alors c'est toi le fameux cause
c'est toi la fameuse loi
[Musique]
tu as lu moi genève
je me sens ça
j'ai envie de sa bouche [ __ ] un genre
là
c'est combien en fait 4 5
tout vrai quelque chose ça me paraît
très sain contre ans et de l'âge
contrant c'est la guerre qu'est ce qu'on
fait
[Musique]
bienvenue dans osmosis êtes vous prêt à
découvrir ce qu'est vraiment l'amour
tout le monde a une âme soeur
c'était écrit sur l'annoncé je me suis
dit mémoire
implanté
celui de mac os x je suis accro au sexe
auquel est quelqu'un que je vais me
chose avec la ddt de martin notre
intelligence artificielle
j'ai l'immense honneur de vous présenter
en exclusivité une expérience
révolutionnaire pour rencontrer votre
âme soeur
des gens
[Musique]
à
participent à un protocole d'étude est
dans tout et tu viens de matter
nous entendons ascension
on c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
six ans
tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
propos comment le faire
ainsi
[Musique]
mais
bonjour cligner des yeux si vous pouvez
c'est très bien vous pourriez me dire
combien de doigts je vous montre 4 nous
sommes en quelle année on est en 2016
oui très bien et qui est le président
barack obama qui j'ai réussi je suis
passé rien ne s'est passé comme je
l'avais imaginé je vous en prie
permettez mademoiselle azarova
c'est ici que j'ai vite nous avons
voyagé dans une autre dimension dans une
autre version de nous mêmes est-ce que
tu comprends que nous sommes au début de
quelque chose de vertigineux
c'est de l'ordre du petit fin je
m'appelle karim washington je suis
détective privé je cherche une fille qui
a disparu elle vivait dans votre maison
c'est la personne qui est disparu on
dirait que vous avez vu un fantôme
cette photo m'a rappelé un jeune homme
que j'ai connue dans le michigan
tout est lié on a une chance d'y trouver
des réponses
tu es plus forte que ton amer des plus
gentils comme à l'air
omer
rachel ce que tu es renata
bba les garçons
je t'ai demandé croire à des choses
impossibles à croire
et pas une fois tu ne m'a regardé comme
si j'étais dingue
tout ce qui entre ici on sent
complètement barge on ne ressent pas du
tout il va falloir ouvrir les yeux
je ne commencerai pas à toi c'est pas le
moment de jouer les courageuses c'est le
moment des chutes et cette beauté
cette énergie
qu'est ce qui les rend cohérente
qu'est-ce qui l'empêchent de n'être que
des sons forme
lumières scène dans 5 4 3 2
la magie tournoi sans relâche autour de
nous elle est dans l'air que nous
respirons
mais attention n'ayez pas la naïveté de
croire que nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir maîtriser sa puissance
[Musique]
félicitations pour votre admission à
l'université de belgrade
tiens tiens déjà une question qu'est ce
que tu sais au sujet de l'ordre de la
rose bleue c'est bidon cette histoire de
sociétés secrètes
[Musique]
vous êtes sur le point de vivre une des
plus grandes aventures de votre vie
[Musique]
il semblerait que vous ayez été choisi
acceptez-vous votre devoir
oui
nous espérons que vous accomplirez de
grandes choses
bienvenue dans l'ordre mon devoir est de
t'apprendre à utiliser la magie pour
mentor
le hasard a voulu qu'on se retrouve
ensemble on va dire que j'ai eu la
chance il ya une créature qui rôde la
deux le dessin et du v6 mais toutes nos
nouvelles recrues
quant à sion la plus puissante qui ait
jamais été inventé
peut faire tout devient possible
je ne fais rien il va y avoir encore
plus de morts
nous allons bâtir un monde
extraordinaire
ce pourquoi tu as signé dès le départ la
ceni chargée
la magie a toujours un coût et si tu
payes pas le prix ça peut mal se passer
ca c